creating new markets comes from seeing
the world through new eyes it's about
having a fundamentally different
perspective on the way the world works
we're often looking for a reframe at
jump right we're looking for a
fundamental shift in perspective that
makes you think wow I thought the world
worked this way and it actually works
this way it's a completely different
change you know in wired to care I write
about one of my students and they do
those kind of reframes and they're
incredibly powerful when you get a
reframe it's it's it's like taking that
pill and in the movie The Matrix and you
thought the world was one thing and then
suddenly the world is all numbers and
you can't go back to the view that you
had before I had a student a couple
years ago and we had asked him to go out
and study what cleaning look like right
and so we had you know 50 of America's
best and brightest right these are all
Stanford students and they're studying
how to old people clean and had a young
people clean and how do Latinos clean
and in the final presentation they were
doing a presentation to Clorox because
there were our corporate sponsor and
this guy was up there and use presenting
how young people clean you know what the
world of an 18 year old looks like which
is not a pretty picture when it comes to
cleaning right and he's presenting out
you know his story it is showing video
and this vice president from Clorox kind
of cuts him off at the middle says wait
a minute it sounds like you're telling
me the people your age don't care about
cleaning nearly as much as people my age
and we should forget about you and this
guy says no that's not what I'm saying
I'm saying the people have come to view
the world through some basic frames
based on whatever they've experienced in
their life and there are some people who
for whatever they experienced earlier on
view all of the world around them is
being made up of durable goods that the
stuff around you will last a table a
chair you take care of it you keep it
looking like new because it'll be with
you for a long time and there's other
people who view all these same things as
disposable goods so if you get a scratch
in the table it's no big deal you throw
it out and you get a new table right so
there are people with a durable good
mentality and people with a disposable
good mentality and people who are the
age of this rut vice president tend to
view the world
being made up of durable things things
that last and people who are 17 or 18
years old tend to view the world is
being made up of disposable things
because they're on their third personal
computer by the time they're 18 they're
on their fifth cell phone and they say
things to their parents like mom can we
get a new car this one has a rattle in
it I mean that's how they view the world
and then the student mind kind of looked
at the VPS and here's a real clincher
everything that Clorox makes everything
that you produce speaks to the world as
if it was durable it says keep it
looking like new keep it looking like
the day you bought it and you have an
entire generation of people coming up
who think well why would I do that why
would I just throw it out and get a new
one and this is a fundamental problem
it's also a fundamental reframe you know
for this vice president if you think
about it she walked into the room
thinking that her business was about you
know having a nice lemon scent and you
know it killing bacteria and maybe
cutting cleaning time in half and here
were some guys who after starting the
world so that's all great but it is
totally irrelevant to an entire group of
people because they see the world a
different way